all right everybody my name is gm jesse
cry
and the st louis chess club
erroneously by some mistake let me
hey there ryan reynolds owner of mint
mobile
whatever i wanted to do for this video
and i just said you know what
i want to collect some of the chess best
chess videos that i've never seen
i'm going to play these things for your
enjoyment
maybe i'll say something funny maybe
i'll crack up if they're boring i'm just
going to the next one
i'm just going to go to the next one
that's going to be my process
all right let's get have some fun man
let's see how this goes
it's the holidays and then
let's turn it up yeah
[Music]
this is the daniel gormley show my
friends
[Music]
oh i like it already i like the audio in
the video ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the danny gormali show
that's really good so to start off with
i'm gonna do gentleman jim plaskett
who's a very uh notorious chess player
and he won a quarter of a million on who
wants to be a millionaire very
intelligent guy
yeah incredible memory this guy plaskett
i've been fo
following him on twitter and uh
totally weird dude um he lives in spain
now
he did a video that was like poorly
produced but great content
with kasparov like back in the day
and uh on twitter the dude is like uh
he's like got a thing against
evolutionary theory he's got like this
rant i don't know anyways interesting
guy also like a little bit older me
trying to
come back to chess it's hard here let's
see the impersonation
and uh it was guys go molly this is my
game against uh lobon from lucerne 1983.
incredible game amazing game uh
you see my game against chris tarrant on
who wants to be a millionaire
a wonderful game and as of course
there's a famous anecdote to tell you
earlier a guy goes up to him and he goes
um excuse me mr plasca see anything
better than castles in that position
and uh uh plus it goes and goes
you still got a video because i really
love made him warm what do you think
nice nothing sadly is kind of like this
very sort of uh
seriously yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i love it man i love it
[Music]
matthew sadler of course is now all into
the a.i
but back in the day before he went to
finance or something like that
but uh that guy was amazing that guy
could have been
one of the top players in the world
[Music]
that's really good all right this is
gonna be great
[Music]
that's pretty good
[Music]
then you'll go from the border
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
then it's back full
well yeah i was watching a girlfriend
versus uh
uh and uh i was very unimpressed by the
quality of the play
clearly vichy is not playing anything
like as strong as usual and girlfriend
is uh
he is only doing 12 hours a day on chess
he is not doing like me i'm doing 16
hours a day
just on rook and morning games you know
i mean what is wrong with these people
they are not
uh professional chess players you know
anand is not the
fourth force he wants you know when i
played gary
you know we knew up to move 40 every
position
okay so that that that should probably
suffice for now but hopefully i can
think of some other
good chess players to do an impression
of in future
all right that was fun that was fun that
was from 2014.
you can get that on the ginger gm
channel
all right next up we've got a new one
this came out this summer this is a
parody
of some drama that went down
uh with hikaru all right
here we go that's xqc on the left and uh
and that's where i don't know how to how
to do that guy's name
he's over there on the right and here we
go
boom
nice
[Music]
look hikaru and qvc what's what's the
idea here
mr monkey bing bing boom
bing bing boom bing bing boom bing bing
boo bing bing boom bing bing boom bing
bing boom
spam this flower to give
[Music]
is a game for everyone a very accurate
statement elitism in chess
ignores the haters
nakamura nakamura chess is the ultimate
game it's just the best
it's for the community a new boom for
chess
[Music]
wow that is awesome
negative talent in life chess is a
wonderful game
try enjoy it and you'll see that
okay that was that was like tops man
that was top
yeah so i think that was that was
originally
i got motor i have been such a chess
elitist that i haven't uh
checked out the dude's channel even
though like a lot of his vids are
getting like
millions millions of views so that's on
me
all right next up mention in that video
what's ben feingold
let's see the best defend feingold right
now part one
this guy i always want to say ben
feingold is
a prob a lot of people know he's a funny
dude
i've hung out with a bunch of times and
the most surprising thing about ben that
people don't know
is the man can dance you look at him
you're like well he's not going to dance
we went out to some clubs and stuff
in chicago we played a round robin over
there back in the day
dude can dance do condense i saw it in
st louis too
all right here we go when you are not
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
let's do it who dares challenge me
i dare anyone and everyone hammer was
doing one minute blindfolds
yeah but who yeah i could do one minute
blindfold but that's too easy
okay so let's do some blindfolds you
know with josh
okay 49 second blindfold now i have a
question
no i'm going to do it i have a question
are you ready no yeah
okay tell me the move i haven't moved
yet
right
one minute before e6 e6 e6 e6 e6
oh this is not gonna work out g5 d5 d5
e3 what e3 there's no e3
they played e3 i thought he played e4 on
move one d4
oh like he had an understanding
knight f6 i'm going to the next one
this is funny it's not that funny let's
go to the next moment next best moment
here we go
fast forward this class that was
protected and now it's not
i wish i could take it how could i
attack his pawn hold on let me think
about it
man how could i attack that pawn do
if i play rook f4 my computer will blow
up and the lecture will end
do it so i'm like oh boy i got all my
pieces ready to go to e4
i'm the best okay now
he did it again britney spears style
okay so was knight takes pawn good for
white or good for black
black close i'll give you one more guess
white yeah yeah because if you take
check
notice it's checked because i said so no
and what would gregory kaidanov say
he would say black is up a king
okay this guy's 1900 so that should beat
him right
that should do it
[Laughter]
yeah st louis man that guy was in st
louis forever
helped establish the club
i don't know if i could take this one
though where's your night going i'm just
wondering
that's all i was wondering oh that's
where it's going
resigns he didn't know the theory
he knew knight f6 knight g8 knight f6
knight g and not f6 knight g8 knight f6
but then he didn't donate oh man oh yeah
oh oh he didn't know that
ridiculous yeah horrible this is a kid's
class
if you can call them kids two force i
just want to say i've done this kid's
class in st
louis and st louis if you're watching
this is some of the cruelest stuff
you've ever subjected the gm's and
residents to
it's totally brutal those kids are evil
they don't even want to be there their
parents are just sticking up there look
at it's a cold rainy day
outside no one wants to be there man
they can't take it they want out
i've been in there those kids have
abused me man and now we're doing some
online stuff
and it's much better because i got we're
on zoom and stuff and i'm just
mute mute them mute them here we go
let's see how ben
dealt with it six eight kids terrible
aren't you guys ashamed that your
brethren didn't show up they look pretty
ashamed
okay no talking yeah this is live right
now they can hear you no we trade
no no no screaming raise your hand if
you want to she's gonna ask the question
about knight takes d4 again
don't talk unless you raise your hand
and don't raise your hand
all right don't don't talk unless you
raise your hand we do have security here
this is clearly ben's favorite trick
here the knight takes d4 trick
plays b5 that pawn's hanging it's free
that's called the benko gambit the
bengko gambo is named after who
mr gambit ask me why i'm gonna say i
don't know
okay and then i castle so
notice every move i make every breath i
take
man f5 wins a piece e5 wins appease
king f2 wins a piece queen h6 wins a
piece
damn exactly if he takes i'll play knife
f5
that's true where was i gonna made him i
forgot
now he made a good move so i got really
mad and i called the director
i said come on you know this guy he
can't make a good move we all agreed and
he'd take it back
you see all these pawns that are in red
and you see all these pawns that are in
green
[Music]
because it's like christmas time i'm
gonna tell you a shocking story
they're all protected
we need to build a wall exactly build
the wall
lock somebody up something something
dark side
trump 2020 no how many classes do we
used to have
archer incorrect ocean
four four what are you playing golf what
are you donald trump
are you dead evil or no no not yet
you're too young
you'll get there right right trump's
your favorite
no no no her not you have you heard of
donald trump say no
say no
uh what are they gonna say let's see
trump's still good
okay yeah i took my own bishop
worse than i thought no no the first
class
i said me and this kid goes wait a
minute you could do the winter rook and
the queen
and then and i was like but i made him
he's like but you could have won a rook
and then i was like isn't mate better he
was like okay maybe
but why didn't you win the rook and i
was like black has one legal move
can you find it um there's two of them
no there's one
i wouldn't lie to you grandmaster oh
yeah there's one
yeah the other one's illegal whatever
that's oh my god yeah and now
shocking the whole audience and those of
you at home you guys got to calm down
no no have a seat you might fall to your
chair
white has made in one move but it's
really hard it's hard it's hard
but it's hard i don't know uh we'll call
it a random student you
um here's a funny comment in the youtube
he's saying that feingold lost a lot of
popularity after the whole excuse the
naca thing he said some stuff about naca
hanging out with people that were
beneath him and that kind of stuff but
honestly that just drove more traffic to
the old feingold dude
i think anyways i don't yeah that was
good news is bad news for him
move the pump to chief you'll get your
whisper again i don't think that's me
because i could take the pawn i can move
my king there's actually made in one
move
are you shocked yeah that's me
it mates good cause you win knife f5 and
black would resign
for example a6 boo
knight f5 resigns
if you don't believe me let's turn on
the computer for nothing if we cancel
we lose a knight for nothing
knife f5 yeah now you got it
i'm telling you that with that class st
louis man it's brutal
draw arrows for the crowd because you
come over there to st
louis you leave your family back home
wherever you're from
and you're like i'm gonna get some nice
time in st louis hang out with some
chess people
you know maybe take care of myself a
little bit
you know have a nice time just a little
relax that's the way it sounds it's like
gm
in residence it's like oh this is gonna
be great man
this is gonna be a great time and then
they stick you with that kid's class and
you're traumatized for life man
do that wait i could draw arrows yay
look at me
i'm sandra i almost said it too
all right except you won't see yourself
you'll see me i'm attacking his knight
i'm attacking his knight and then your
last terminal
yeah the more classy you come to the
more i get paid okay also you guys
didn't donate lately
terrible you thought i was terrible look
at you look in the mirror don't do that
it'll break
bishop d3 retreating like a
frenchman he's in new orleans so of
course no i retreated like a frenchman
bishop e6 and so now he's losing a
knight
and he should lose the game but he was
playing me
so he had a chance so my knight's
attacked twice
and i can't defend it
my bishop's not defended
i mean i could have made a much better
joke edit that killer i beat him in 17
moves you know why
i was black okay and he did something
you never heard of
called removing the defender
okay and i told you this story before
you want to rob a bank
and then you're like oh it's sunday i
guess i'll go to kids class
okay and you go to the bank and you're
all ready to rob the bank but there's a
security guard there
so you go home and cry what you should
have done is brought a donut with you
then you put the donut outside the
security guard goes and gets it then you
rob the bank
now tall occasionally would drink
alcohol
and occasionally would smoke okay but
tall was born
sick like lady gaga and this is called
the vallamirovich attack named after mr
attack attack very good now bishop d7
which looks innocuous right archer sure
okay
it looks like bishop d7 he's developing
his bishop so what
not so what so mom and jar of
two if i yeah so he's playing a good
defensive game
he's just some terrible two it's a very
sharp sewzing with checkmates every move
he makes is boring and defensive
somehow i won i'm white and we played
your favorite opening
the nimzo indian named after which grand
master
that was his name nimzo indian you know
funny name
but that's what the master does or the
blindfold player
he doesn't put a blindfold on he sits
there with his back
to the people that he's playing what we
saw today was
a grand master player with a nearly
photographic memory
he visualizes it as if a camera
is looking down as if he was looking
through a camera that's looking
down now you can take the knight or go
back
i've done both but not at the same time
all right
now i know arthur pretty well he doesn't
play like this
this is when he was young and foolish
eight now he's 10
double digits now he plays solid he
doesn't
katie doesn't taste good to him anymore
double digits you know
they've been married and divorced twice
you know since this game
yeah okay one of his kids is in college
man
the other one we will talk about him
what a disappointment
okay how can i how could i how can i
raise my hand
you incorrect
you
oh man he's just making the best look at
that he's got two lacroix over there
even just trying to make it through just
trying to make it through man you mean
no
then his pawn would take and i would cry
also you played
this tournament and you played and you
and you get a new car
did archer play i think so you guys are
telling the wrong jokes
didn't you get the script i sent you no
because theory and practice are the same
in theory but not in practice
okay i try to remember yeah all right i
mean i said theory in practice
you don't know that one you come to all
my lectures yeah you take notes
it's in your notes somewhere okay i mean
it is true
i just realized that people in the
comments were saying
there's a reason that those classes
those one o'clock classes with the
so-called rookies why they're not
streamed anymore why they're not
recorded
it got too vicious in there my friends
you don't want to go there
on a sunday you think you're doing
something relaxing with your kids you're
not
they'll be traumatized for life theory
of sin is no it's put out in practice
all right so arthur wins hooray and his
opponent cries
and i'm not kidding about that either
yeah the world at the world youth and
world cadet the only question i ask my
students is did your opponent cry
50 50. and what was my favorite answer
who
remembers previous lectures what was my
favorite answer when i asked that
i bet ben simone was taping this he's
taping me now i bet ben simone was there
you that's just the usual answer i had a
much better answer than that the game
was about 30 moves
and my students said my opponent started
crying on move 12
and did it through the rest of the game
and i was like
and what's funny was it was the last
round so that's the thing
when the kid cried for 11 rounds after
around 11 you're like i won't cry
anymore
like i've already lost six games hey he
cried for the whole game
wow okay i i gave him i give him an
extra treat that was good
okay cause making your opponent cry
that's what chess is all
now black is in wang chung i mean
zugzwan
black can't do vishwa nothing
it's true yeah he can't do any of the
white's pieces all over
black is defending against knight c5 but
it's not a threat
this is called the ken west syndrome and
grand master ken west
is currently playing in vegas and
getting recognized
he was posting on facebook i'm walking
in vegas and they're like
you're ken west and you're like yeah
you're the ken west
and he's like i'm a ken west yeah so ken
west
and mike cummer irrespective of their
playing ability
get recognized all over the country
because of our videos
he's got something simon what'd you get
there i've got some i'll go ahead and go
straight
freeway let me get some of these nuts in
my mouth
come on ben show it to me okay that's
that's what she said
okay let's go here yay hey my running's
really high i gotta play you more often
okay seven o'clock all right that was
pretty cool guys
that was pretty cool actually i need i
didn't get
a simon williams uh vid
up on here we'll see all right i got
another one
let's move it along this is from back in
the day this is the extreme chess
championships
i was hanging out earlier with the crowd
online
and then i was asking them what's your
favorite shows you know what's your
favorite you chess youtube video so here
we go this is one of them
i didn't have the stomach to watch it
back in the day here we go boom welcome
to the extreme chess
championship today we have eight of the
best
young chess players in america competing
to be
the first extreme chess champion so i
saw
casa corley uh alyssa malaquina
and elliot lou and i think just eustis
justice williams is in there too
if he lived in europe his name would be
used i don't know i said that here we go
[Music]
crushing everyone's soul is in the realm
of possibility
whenever you lose you're not happy
[Music]
i think i'm gonna win
i've always wondered what happened to
that kid uh
i don't know if he's still playing or
what what a scene is i know alyssa went
out and did some finance stuff and
elliot did all kinds of cool stuff i
don't know what he's
he's po he's like an instagram poster
now man he's got your lifestyle
i'm craving parks from manhattan to
brooklyn
a lot of girls are better than guys i
have the best chess tactics
i'm gonna play aggressively and go for
the best
[Music]
i'm chess expert jonathan corbla and
this is two-time u.s women's champion
jennifer shahadi
in the chess room we have international
chessmen nice sweater bro
nice host casey marie extreme chess
is extreme because it's way faster than
these guys are used to playing
they have less than 20 minutes to make
all their moves in most tournaments they
have hours
a double-sided cockpit track when you're
out of time
you lose the game fakes are high but
who's gonna win
we have some really exciting players we
have sean
and casa playing in the first game and
we also have justice versus kevin
then we've got elena a relative newcomer
to the high stakes chess we're all
playing against alex the highest rated
guy in the crew and we have a jet setter
elliot who just came from italy
gonna play against alyssa alyssa is not
only one of the top female players in
america
she's also a philosophy student and a
dancer i didn't know she was a
single elimination knockout we need more
of we need more of
melakina dancing what would we do who's
a single game they're out of here we
have our host
casey marie who's gonna give us a little
refresher on the rules of chess
first let's set up the pieces there's
eight pawns oh my god the rules let's
get the rules
sean versus casa how do you feel about
your match-up with casa i feel like i'm
gonna have to
definitely fight very hard should be a
great match i've known sean um we've
gone
back and forth a couple times of course
there's a little butterflies
at this point it's more about what i can
control and that's my play
i think i'm i'm calm cool and collected
calm cool and collected casa is still
playing i think he's jammed now i think
he's got like he's like half
a danish or some some kind of
scandinavian thing anyways it goes back
and forth i think with europe
he just did a cool video um from the us
chess school
that we're now hosting at the chess dojo
that's
kind of cool just like that's 2011
basically this video we're watching
2011. that's like 10 years ago
fun to see who's still in chess and
who's who's out extreme chef game one
start your class we are off the clocks
are
started with sean against casa
shawn playing white and castle playing
black playing
a variation of the sicilian defense
called the night or
favorite of american world champion
bobby fisher
the sicilian is a very popular opening
which begins when white pushes his king
pawn forward two squares
to e4 and the opponent responds by
moving their queen's bishop pawn
forward two squares to c5 the sicilian
is known for producing the most exciting
games in chats
i like to play basketball and i run
track as well
i enjoy playing video games school have
been
dominating my life i guess so now is
that growing dominating
i like to experience more things in life
go to parties hang out with friends
sean was partying late the last night
before
and some of the players said they wanted
to play against sean because he was uh
you know dancing late last night at the
club
i think playing him in the first round
would be pretty much a free point
we'll have to see whether this helps or
hurts sean it looks like sean just
castled queen side
castling is the only time in chess where
you can move two pieces at once
you develop all the pieces oh i can't
take it i can't take it
but what happened sean one thing about
this video that's actually interesting
is now we
are kind of experimenting there's been a
number of experiments
kind of like this where you have like
the chess dojo we had the ultimate
sensei where they like trained with the
person
and then it was like a reality show to
see who was the best
there's we had the streamer battles bot
battles coming up
so it's like this was 2011 pretty good
production quality
i like how they spliced all the footage
in together
uh but then i never saw anything like
that until this last year
where now there's more of it going on
with like
chess as a reality show kind of thing
all right well couple more minutes i'll
go to the next one
that moved around this is a fantastic
blunder on jon's part
this is the turning point in the game
everyone because he just snapped that
rook off like it was a christmas present
shawn is definitely shaking right now i
think that sean
sean was partying last night that when
casa takes his rook he's also attacking
the queen which is the most powerful
piece in the war
maybe sean still had the base pounding
his ears from last night and wasn't able
to
see that his rook was about to get
kicked out in this tournament
if you lose a single game i've never
heard of that i don't know sean
i don't know all right let's go now he's
got him boxed it
he's back very smooth performance by
anxious about playing first and no one
wants to be the first to walk away
as long as i worry about myself and not
about my opponents
i think anything is possible for our
next game we have
justice versus kevin two of our youngest
players in the entire extreme
chess championship this is going to be
exciting games oh yeah
in fact they are our two young nice face
buddy nice face interesting that they
got paired against each other in the
very first round
and justice the youngest
african-american
master in history and kevin a very
strong
chess master from maryland let's see
what the players have to say pro tip uh
there's a cool uh documentary called
brooklyn castle and
justice williams is in that one along
with a lot of other people that i'm
interested
you know see how what ended up happening
to him you know that was also a way back
that's something that's not really a
youtube video i'm looking for short
videos but that's definitely
something i'd also want to follow up on
a lot of these people
sean kevin no idea who they are so how
do you feel about the magic with justice
are you feeling nervous at all not
really i think it's a good experience
because i haven't played justice at all
i'll see what's like
justice how do you feel about the
matchup with kevin i can't wait to play
extreme chess round one game two with
the white pieces we have justice
williams
with the black pieces we have kevin wang
start your class
[Music]
justice you know he's playing a very
mature opening
for such a young player he's playing an
opening called the catalan
the catalan is an opening that combines
pushing your queen pawns forward
the d-pawn and the c-pawn and the
enchanting
your king bishop putting it in the
corner of the board it's a very strong
piece
and later in the game it might end up
really wrecking havoc now justice puts
the king in check
all right that's that that's a double
attack actually because he's going to
tell ben
that kevin buddy so that's always good
and in chess
you can only make one move at a time so
if your opponent puts you
in check and attacks a pawn they're
going to be able to least get something
out of it
i like tennis i usually watch basketball
i play clarinet
[Music]
i like that i kind of really focused on
my school studies
when i watch football i like the packers
checkmate both players are developing
their pieces which is such an important
thing to do in the beginning of the
chess game
and castling both of them have castle so
both of them have pre-safe kings
justin seems to be really taking a long
time for his moves while
kevin's moving really quickly and
confidently well you can't do that in
the extreme chess championship because
the players start with less than 20
minutes on the clock so time is
definitely precious
what strikes me interesting is that even
though there are two of our youngest
players you're two of our most mature
players as well
both quiet understated these guys have
nothing but chess on their mind
what it would be like to be 12 years old
by now
that was a good taste of that vid let's
do the next vid this is gonna be
i just you know what i did i don't know
anything
about i got mator i'm probably saying it
dude's name wrong
but i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna
figure this dude out i want to taste
this guy's videos i'm a chess elitist
i've been avoiding the guy
i just went to his webpage and i was
like which one has the most
uh views and so this one
was somehow anna rudolph being accused
of that engine
hidden in her lap her lip balm even so
here we go
amazing that this dude has got so many
views on
youtube by far i mean way more than
anybody else millions
it's it's mind-boggling actually think
about millions
of views for various videos on
chess on youtube amazing all right let's
check it out
welcome to a video that features a most
interesting story
a story that went viral some 10 years
ago it's about a tournament
it was a it was a chess tournament
played in vendevere in 2008
and uh we will feature one game it's a
christian bauer
a french grandmaster against anna
christian bauer super strong guy i
played in the bundesliga
with him well 1999. he was just like a
young pup
rudolph uh and this is the event where
anna rudolph won both her international
masternodes and
women grand master norms uh he started
she started the tournament with a win in
round one and now she faces the top seed
in the tournament it's
like we said uh french grand master
christian bauer
and it is after this game that this
whole story begins as it's quite
interesting
we'll discuss it a bit later but first
let's check out the game but even before
game we do have a nice photo challenge
uh it's a nice photo by david lada so
best of luck to everyone
i will give you a couple of hints it's a
very good friend of
anna rudolf and also she is anish
geary's wife
so there you have it best of luck to
everyone now let's check out
this game already uh from the first move
the grand master uh
chooses uh not an everyday approach he
goes for b4
uh the polish bauer was always playing
crazy stuff though
every time against everybody opening uh
we have e5
the standard reply and now not going for
bishop b2 immediately but
rather a3 and okay we have d5
it's a standard the most standard
principle there exists if your opponent
allows you to take control of the center
uh then by all means do take control of
the center
so okay bishop b2 knight to d7 e3
bishop to d6 simply developing c4
d captures bishop captures on c4 knight
g to f6
uh knight to f3 and we have castles
uh queen to c2 by bower b6 uh
anna prepares to develop the light
square bishop uh d3
bishop to b7 knight bd2 we have a6
that's interesting bauer castles b5
bishop to b3
and now rook the c8 preparing to push c5
uh bauer
contrast this he places d4 keeps control
of the c5 square
uh he captures on b4 e captures and now
bishop to d5
uh oh all right we have bishop captures
knight captures and
now comes knight to e4 preparing to grab
that bishop on d6 but we have knight
seven to b6
and now even though uh grabbing this
bishop might seem like a night idea
knight c5 is also a very nice move and
the c5 square is
i don't get it dude i don't get why this
guy is so popular it's
mind-boggling he's fat he's talking too
fast
huh i mean obviously i'm missing some a
very nice outpost for the night
so by capturing the bishop pawn captures
uh
queen to f5 as the queen is attacked by
the rook queen to f6 and black is
perfectly fine here queen captures
knight captures and uh this bishop
wouldn't have that much fun with all of
these pawns and dark squares it would be
very hard to
to activate it so after knight seven to
b6 rook 8 to d1
instead uh c6 we have knights to c5
and here comes rook to a8 here anna
decides to defend
the a61 uh it's very important to note
this as this was one of the games where
people started being suspicious about
her using
external help uh from some engines or
supercomputers
that this move uh engine never even
mentions it this is a you know the top
recommendation by engine is actually
bishop captures on c5
either bishop not bishop captures on c5
sorry knights to c4
there are a lot of options here rook to
e8 also a nice engine recommendation
bishop captures on c5 is a nice engine
recommendation but the top engine
recommendation is actually knight to c4
sure
a very nice improvement on black's
position
where white is not able to capture the
a6 pawn because now rook to a8
will come with a double attack against
the a3 pawn
after knight goes back knight captures
on a3 and this is now a very
beautiful and active position for black
on the other hand also
knight captures uh bishop captures is an
idea but
then after the captures white would have
a much better pawn structure here on the
queenside
knight here we can play knight d2 knight
capture queen captures
and we would have this very nice pawn
chain while white's
pawns wouldn't be that that great on the
queen side and the
white pawns are on the dark squares but
the white got rid of his uh
weak dark square bishop here so it would
be an all right position
to play for both of them but okay rook
to a8 by anna defending the a6 pawn we
have rook
f2 e1 and then now comes queen to c7
pressuring the h2 pawn
so now you could play something like h3
it's what i would play uh
the grandmaster decided to go for g3 uh
with the same idea preventing uh this
pressure against the h2 pawn but also
keeping an eye on this f4 square not
allowing the knights to go there
uh we have h6 and then now comes knight
to h4
okay preparing to bring the knight over
to f5 uh we have
uh rook after d8 and now comes bishop to
c1
uh with future ideas of maybe
sacrificing on h6
uh bishop to f8 ana brings the bishop to
help out with the defense on the king
side
knight to f5 and now comes a5 as there
are
obviously no tricks on the king side
pawn captures rook captures and
now comes queen to e2 preparing to bring
the queen over to the kingside to join
the attack
uh rogue goes back to a8 now comes queen
to g4
pinning the g7 pawn now knight captures
on h6 is definitely an idea ana moves
the king king to h8 and
now comes queen to h4 with some ideas
now there's a triple attack against the
h6 pawn so perhaps there are some ideas
here
but ana says no there are not uh
rook to e8 is played even though the
engine's suggestion is king to h7
the engine would prefer if the king
joined the defense of the h6 pawn
but okay here i'm most likely i have no
idea
but the grand master probably went into
a deep think as there are so many
options to to play here
uh you have to calculate everything you
have to decide whether
knight captures an h6 is even an idea if
knight captures on g7 is an idea so
we're just gonna cover
uh some basic uh sacrifices here knight
captures
pawn captures bishop captures bishop
capture screen capture so does this work
for white uh
king g8 we have rook characters for
example rope captures and now queen to
g5
if the king goes to the h file then the
queen can of course keep
checking him and this would be a draw by
repetition uh if the king starts running
away
for example queen to h6 check and king
to e7 uh now white uh can bring another
piece into it the attack rook v1 check
king king d8 queen to g5 check
and uh now you have to block this knight
to e7
uh and the knockout is rook to e6 but
most likely the grand master found this
move
uh as it doesn't allow uh black to
to capture it because knight captures
would win the queen and
also it doesn't give black all that many
options white has a very nice attack
very nice position black is up at night
but
those knights are very harmonious at the
moment uh for example king c8 now
getting the
king out of the way now comes queen to
h5 uh pinning this f7 pawn
if you capture then of course you will
lose the game and after rook to f8
the game continues but uh all right i'm
gonna put something in perspective here
this video we're watching here
like nothing special about this video
2.8
million views 2.8 million
you go extreme chess championships 41
000
pretty good but not even close to that
best of ben feingold pretty good 280
000. like for me that's as a chess video
that's that's amazing 280 000.
uh dr hikarus that was actually the best
video of the bunch
that was only this year but still 59
000.
that might have been i think hikaru did
his own reaction video on that one
you know so that's like probably out
there in multiple forms
daniel gormley show we kind of maybe
have to be british to know a little bit
of the people
involved there only 5 000 views so
huge difference in terms of who how many
people
watching is this as a dead draw going
away for it
it's amazing to me too about this is
like the
clutter of his setup not that my
obviously look at my setup
terrible yeah it's absolutely terrible
i'm sorry about that
but in any case how do you get
all those views when you got this like
clutter business going on here i'm going
to fix mine mine is cluttery too
terrible um
anyways i don't understand man really
interesting
how this works all right let's watch a
little bit more and then i'm closing it
out for the night
i'm closing it out for either sides to
make progress
but uh i'm sure the grand master spent a
lot of time here
uh another thing aside from this knight
captures here you could also go knight
captures here but it
brings us to a pretty much same position
captures captures captures
and after king j8 we reach the same
position
also possible after this rook to e8 move
is to simply first capture it and then
after captures
uh you can go into the same variation
yet again captures captures captures
captures and then we reach queen g5
check
where we can go into the same line so
although uh
white uh can get at least a draw here
the grand master decides it's not worth
it
there's not enough you know uh uh
fuel to power this attack uh he goes
king to g2
he improves the position of his king and
waits for anna's move
uh anna goes queen to d8 immediately
offers a trade of queens
uh we have rook capture 78 queen
captures on e8 and
now comes queen to g4 this was basically
the last moment in the game where the
grand master could have gone for this
bishop captures an h6 idea and after
captures captures captures captures uh
into the
same queen to g5 line uh but here he
played queen to g4 and now it no longer
works here anna played
knight to f6 uh attacking uh bauer's
queen
queen to f3 and then now knight b to d5
uh we have
g4 uh white doesn't really have all that
much to push for
to push with so he has to play something
g5 uh
h4 g5 definitely an idea uh b capture
bishop captures on c5 d captures on c5
and now queen to e4
here anna says that uh her pawn
structure is better
uh white has a weak a3 pawn and he has a
funny bishop on c1 that
has to keep an eye on this pawn uh it
will be it will be a much better
position for black but
white doesn't have all that many options
h3 is played defending the pawn uh
king the g g8
[Laughter]
now tracy's making fun of me about the
layout i'm using that was
that's the only layout you guys gave me
there's another one
all right i have to admit i'm shamed i'm
shamed because i was talking trash
about this dude who's got way more views
than anything i'd ever had put together
and then i was making fun of his layout
and then
my layout pretty janky too in any case
i'm gonna end it there i hope you
enjoyed these videos i like the idea of
doing more reaction videos
um it's just a chance for me to like
see some of this stuff i might not
normally because i'm an old chess
elitist might not normally look at
i also want to do a show at some point
where i'm looking at videos
that are more you know instructional in
quality
and i want to hear you know if somebody
has some great videos
they want to share send it to me on the
twitch
not on the twitter that would be the
best way send me on twitter jessecry
and uh i'll take it from there all right
uh
till next time